نشر السلاح النوويه التكتيكيه الروسيه في
الاراضي البيلاروسيه يثير قلق القوى
الغربيه وواشن تصفه بالخطير ما هي هذه
الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه التي اربكت
الغرب لهذه الدرجه من بين تلك الاسلحه
مشاهدينا صواريخ جويه مزوده برؤوس نوويه
ستحملها 10 طائرات تابعه لسلاح الجو
البيلاروسي وسيتم تجهيز تلك الطائرات
لتكون قادره على حمل رؤوس اسلحه نوويه
يبلغ مداها 2500 كم وفقا طبعا للاعلام
الروسيه الاسلحه تشمل ايضا منصات منظومه
اسكندر العملاتيه تكتيكيه التي يمكن ان
تصيب صواريخها اهدافا تبعد مسافه
2500 كيلومترات ايضا وباستطاعه الراس
القتلي الذي يحمله صاروخ اسكندر ان يحدث
انفجارا بقوه 50 كيلو طنا اي ما يزيد
بمقدار عن نح ثلاثه اضعاف عن قوه القنبله
التي تم اسقاطها عام 1945 على هيروشيما
اليابانيه اما السلاح النووي الاستراتيجي
الروسي هنا طبعا فيكمن ويمكن ان تنشره
موسكو ايضا بموافقه بيلاروسيا لانها لا
يزال فيها اكثر من ثمانين منصه ثابته تحت
الارض لصواريخ الباليستيه العابره للقارات
في حاله تقنيه جيده ويمكن هنا لروسيا ان
تضرب بسلاحها التكتيكي اي نقطه في اي دوله
تابعه في اوروبا في حال طبعا تعرضها او
حلفتها بيلاروسيا لاي هجوم محتمل خلال هذه
الحرب
[موسيقى]